507 on your Monday morning back here at
home what's driving you crazy how about
chewing up another chunk of Charleston
this time it's the city of Las Vegas
adding another choppy chapter to the
checkered changes challenging Charleston
drivers okay it's a less than a mile
stretch between mlki 15 and Rancho but
even without construction traffic
through the Medical District can be
tough this 38 million dollar sewer water
main project will also Rock Rancho from
okey to the south of Charleston up to
Alta near the 95.
now we're not talking about complete
closures for either street but you might
be better off avoiding both the city's
recommended alternates well for
East-West travel while Charleston is
chunked up they're saying Okie or Alta
or maybe pinto and palomino now for
north-south driving while Ranchos are
wreck you might be better off over on
Valley View you can also try MLK Shadow
Lane or Campbell now this project is
scheduled to run for a year and a half
so doing the math is going to be August
of 2024 before things get back to
whatever normal might be buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone and
join the driving you crazy conversation
at traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com